por más de 20 años Clarence Thomas
magistrado de la Corte Suprema de
Estados Unidos aceptó lujosos Regalos y
vacaciones de parte de El Millonario de
Texas
iba en sus yates privados alrededor del
mundo viajaba en sus aviones y se
hospedaba en las mansiones así lo reveló
el medio Pro pública acá en Estados
Unidos esto sin revelar precisamente
estos lujosos viajes y atenciones que
recibía por parte del millonario que
además ayudó en el 2011 a financiar la
creación del partido político
ultraconservador el tipo que además
fundó la esposa del magistrado Jim
Thomas al respecto congresistas
demócratas entre ellos Alexandra Ocasio
Cortés han pedido la renuncia del
magistrado diciendo que este grado de
corrupción es casi caricaturesco y
recientemente también el magistrado
reaccionó diciendo que este tipo de
atenciones este tipo de lujos que estaba
recibiendo por parte del millonario no
creía que los tenía que reportar a las
autoridades